we're bad people make good TV
unreal opens its mansion doors
exclusively for et Jeffrey Boyer Chapman
who plays J on lifetime's bachelor
inspired scripted drama is showing me
where the magic can really happen this
is essentially where all of the girls
reside once they are cast on the show of
everlasting and we stick them in here
for nine weeks with no cell phone no
books no internet and they just fight to
the death for love
of course this here is the control room
the headquarters the brains of
everlasting this is where it all goes
down this is Jai's desk right here okay
this is Rachel's desk right here this is
Quinn here she likes to be at the head
of things for obvious reasons you look
really good there I think I could
produce now this is this is where we
call the shots all you need is like is a
walkie you got your monitors you see
what's going on all around the mansion
every just in case our cameras check out
the bedrooms next first up the girls
room one share then the mancave of the
everlasting suitor right why would
anyone ever want to leave you the
everlasting mansion I don't know maybe
because you make their lives a living
hell so this is the glam room here where
all the magic happens where the
eyelashes get put on the extensions get
locked in and the girls get glamour s it
also has perfect lighting for selfies
next up we head to the fake outdoor set
well isn't it so cheesy it really is
this here is where a lot of like the day
dates go on we had all of this last year
but the rest of this all of this is
brand new for us
so like I'm seeing the details of this
for the first time right now in the
light of day and it is gorgeous
okay so this is a breakdown of all of
the apps for one episode of everlasting
pool time sex I see the pool party we
had so thank you for coming and checking
out our unreal world it's pretty cool
right I cannot wait for season 2 me too
same hey guys make sure you check out
season 2 of unreal when it premieres
June 6 only on lifetime